for the first time in his life he's got
no plan he's checkmated by his sister he
is angry he's
broken sad Dr sad's not the word I mean
um and yeah I mean and and I think with
this guy when he doesn't have a plan
it's just boiling anger
and that's dangerous I mean he is a
killer he is a he does have this in him
so I I I think he's more dangerous than
he may appear to be only because he's so
broken we're all going to prison you
know it is the eighth wonder of the
world you aren't already there what type
of fan reactions are you getting these
days are people feeling a little
sympathetic for for your character or
are they like oh no we are team Beth all
the way I'll get both I get a lot of
both
it's really interesting people are torn
on Jamie but often torn within
themselves you know they both hate him
and they love him yeah to the point
where people yell out at grocery stores
that they hate me but they're smiling I
mean they're laughing yeah yeah
it's always questions about you know
they're worried about me whether I'm
okay you know like there's a bit of
therapy and my fan interactions these
days because I just make sure I'm gonna
survive it oh my gosh do people because
y'all live like on location while you're
shooting this in a sense right yes do
you feel like you get more fan
interactions there or back in your in
your your hometown where you live with
your family I live in L.A and yeah I get
a little less there although I get you
know I get more nods and oh I love your
show and things like that but in you
know anywhere else in the country I go
it's a it's a passionate
discussion about you know the show and
about the state of people and so it
might you know definitely in Montana
they they feel even closer than anyone
else so it's um it's like they're
talking to a friend or something or they
know you downtown right yeah yeah yeah
which is I like I said I I do love that
it means they really are invested West
Bentley's care character Jamie is the
adopted black shape of the Dutton family
or with a laundry list of Secrets he not
only took Beth to get an abortion as a
teen but he also has a secret son
murdered his biological father and is
now at war with his sister who is
blackmailing him I wanna believe that
you're advising what's best for the
family I do
but then I remember
this isn't your family Jamie just like
had quite the Ark last season things did
not end well for him are you hoping
Jimmy can turn things around in season
five well I guess I always hope Jamie
can turn things around so I'm not so sad
myself but
um it's an interesting place for his dad
please please please please please
please please
yeah I feel like the switch is about to
flip might be might be it's gonna have a
table toss in a moment it's just gonna
go bananas but it helps I mean at the
same time that's kind of got to be a fun
character to play too right oh yeah I I
mean this is sort of the dream I have at
least as an actor is I want it to be as
complicated as it can be as I explore
many emotions uh and Jamie is
complicated and I love playing that it's
hard it's really hard in my normal life
a but it's rewarding as an actor because
that that like I said those are the
things I'm I'm looking for I like the
complicated kind of character you know
where everybody's appeared
yeah
because I buried them when you're off
time are you trying to do fun like
really fun out there things because
things can get heavy on the set of
Yellowstone yes and not enough I think I
think I sit and stew in it a lot yeah
it's I think at this point five years in
Jamie's got more of the floor than West
does as we say yeah so it takes a minute
to go home and my kids see Wes instead
of Jamie for a bit and you know that
makes them sad too because Jamie's a sad
guy but um but uh you know it's it's
hard to go off and do things like that I
don't want to distract from it too much
because I like locking in on it
think hard about what you're saying Beth
you're threatening a state official the
drama returns to the Paramount Network
Sunday with Kevin Costner's character
taking his seat in the governor's office
signing this order is a declaration of
war
[Music]
we're already at War so what does this
mean for your political career it means
there is no political career I think in
Jamie's perspective because the one
thing he was going to be for the family
the ones that he wanted to be out of all
of this Arrangement that John had forced
upon him was that hopefully one day he
would be governor and he would have his
own power and his own place in life and
outside the dutton's and
yeah that's uh that's a crushing blow as
well as you know killing his own father
this is two things at once that um he
realizes now that there he will only
ever be that for them it's only he's
only ever what they want him to be and
what they need him to be to the point
where they'll force him to kill
one of his only his only family family
yeah it is by great honor to introduce
you to my choice as the next governor of
Montana
John Dutton that same uh season four
when you're walking down the stairs
thinking that former Governor is going
to endorse you it was like
oh what an awkward moment
it's just you know these little it's
like those little things
[Music]
[Applause]
this season we see Miss Laney Wilson
country music artist tossed into the mix
so we'll visit like heaven this just
genuine human being added to the cast
unfortunately I get to work with her so
I will get to meet her and I was hoping
could have had a jam sesh You Luke Laney
no you know Jamie's World is very
isolating get only getting more so so I
I don't get to meet these cool people I
mean I met my own cool people no one
else gets to me too but um uh she what I
understand she's really nice and I'm
very I'm thrilled she's doing it and I
love her music so
um I'm good I'm glad she's a part of it
just went to shopping wow so
no interest in the dance none I
fortunately got to work with another new
cast member named Don olivieri who um
plays Sarah Atwood from market equities
and she comes on and we have I have some
great scenes with her and she's an
amazing actress uh bring some really
unpredictable stuff and so
um I was excited to work with her
[Music]
I'm gonna make a lot of money Taylor
Sheridan needs no help he just knows how
to do it he knocks it out of the park
every single time but how much does he
include you all in the conversations
about character development his
long-term Vision uh does he keep it
under wraps or does he let you in on a
little bit of it it is a bit of both
yeah I think he gives us for me I don't
need to know a whole lot if Jamie
doesn't know it himself although I
didn't know what the conflict between
Beth and he were I didn't know about the
abortion I had a feeling it was
something like that until we got closer
but yeah he will also share with me
things that um uh that's coming down the
road a bit so I can start to put little
thing you know like to throw little
things into scenes that might had
developed my character in a way that you
can see him heading that way right
instead of just like oh wow unless
that's needed but yeah yeah so he's
great with this great communication with
Taylor for sure I have yet
to stop fighting for this family I was
the reason
that there was no investigation into the
murders at the ranch do you ever have
the opportunity to give your input on
your character development you know I I
would be afraid to I'm not a writer so
yeah you know I I do it through the
acting so I you know he he writes the
scene and then I get up there on the and
do it in in the doing it I guess I'm
putting my imprint of my own yeah
because I'm filling all around the words
and under the words and whatever else I
can do to fill it out and and add
something else to it that but you don't
need to add much to his writing he's
already got it there I am trying to
protect him and the ranch they will
fight you they will fight you dirty is
there any other way
foreign